sweltering through its summer of unrest
Hong Kong prepares for another weekend
of protests a short way across the
border in the mainland city of Shenzhen
a meeting of pro-beijing business and
political leaders is told to support the
beleaguered Hong Kong government at in
tender the who Yuna the spirit conveyed
by the central government is to stop the
violence and end the chaos violence is
not good for Hong Kong at all
hundreds of protesters have been
arrested in increasingly violent clashes
with some now facing prosecution for the
serious offense of rioting that many
lawyers believe is politically motivated
thousands of lawyers staged a protest
how they asked can the Department of
Justice immediately charge the
protesters while the suspected triad
gang members filmed beating up
protesters last month still haven't been
charged
the Department of Justice says it's
above any political interference but the
suspicion is its fast-tracking the
prosecution of people on rioting charges
to keep a lid on the violence although
for many that does nothing to resolve
the underlying problems here like trying
to buy an apartment in the world's most
expensive property market working in
financial services will Lau is
relatively lucky and could one day buy
his own home many he went to college
with can't they don't earn that much
sure so in that case it might take
decades for them to say top of the
deposit for the lump sum then you pay
for poor for the flat for him and the
hundreds of thousands who've been
protesting peacefully
there's the deeper discontent with
inequality and a political system which
doesn't offer the true democracy to
address it we are reason driving people
like myself or you know my peers taking
it to the streets and protesting against
the government is it is that the fact
that we see not just a difficulty but
the fact that we see you know their
growing imbalance in in the system it's
a system under increasing strain not
sure how many more weekend upheavals it
can bear Rob mcbride al Jazeera Hong
Kong